alors que la france s'apprête à durcir
de manière drastique ces mesures
sanitaires en appliquant le post
vaccinales sans surprise les députés
l'ont adopté après plus de trente cinq
heures de discussions au total en europe
de nombreux pays appellent à lever les
restrictions et un retour à la vie
normale enfin quelques signes d'espoir
les indicateurs épidémique semble
fléchir c'est le cas de l'espagne par
exemple qui veut apprendre à traiter le
coc vite comme n'importe quel autre
grippe et qui appelle à cesser de
compter les cas je pense donc que nous
devons aller vers une surveillance de
l'évolution du coc vide comme une
maladie endémique ou encore comme
l'angleterre aujourd'hui où le premier
ministre boris johnson a annoncé la fin
de l'essentiel des réflexions par
conséquent à partir du jeudi de la
semaine prochaine que pas sanitaire
prendra fin avec l'arrivée du variant
micron beaucoup plus contagieux mais
moins virulent l'om est ça va annoncer
que plus de 50 % des européens seraient
contaminés alors levée des restrictions
partout ailleurs faut-il reprendre une
vie normale en france
alors c'est vrai que là on se pose la
question puisqu'on l'a vu un boris
johnson au beau comme on l'appelle ici
jojo aussi bobo au dos a annoncé mettre
fin la semaine prochaine à quasiment
toutes les restrictions en angleterre
enrique casalino professeur merci d'être
là c'est un plaisir de jeu suit péruvien
donc c'est pas une pizza qu'on doit
cette
fois la capitale du pérou lima
partant de là chier médecin spécialiste
en santé publique a twitté hier merci
martin d'être là martin qui rappelle t
il va pas avec le dos de la cuillère à
tout dans lequel vous ironisez sur
l'argent dépensé pour les textes
antiques au vide 1 7 milliard d'euros en
test sur janvier résultat quatre cent
soixante mille 7000 test positif ce soir
les classes fermées les parents excédés
les gens isolés chez eux l'erea bestel
baisse elle s'était pas une question
baisse elles de l'argent bien dépensé on
continue trois petits points plus de
5000 route quinze mille
noms mais s'accroît parce que tu as tout
et surtout l'achetons ce moment non mais
ça parle aux gens je pense que les gens
se posent effectivement la question de
ce qu'on est en train de faire
dépenses 2 milliards à peu près par mois
avec quels résultats c'est des milliards
qui sont dépensés pour freiner
l'épidémie qui flambent plus que dans
n'importe quel pays au monde les gens
pas malades sont soit 4 et chez eux au
train de tester leurs enfants qui
peuvent pas aller à l'école et plus
personne n'en peut un peu de cette
situation et en même temps on a les
réanimations qui baisse et on a les
situations que ça va durer cette
situation là ce n'est pas isolé en
france c'est à dire que c'est la même
chose en italie c'est une chose en
espagne cette chose en grande bretagne
c'est la même chose au danemark donc la
question que je pose en fait c'est la
question que se posent tous les pays du
monde c'est de se dire mais qu'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire avec cette
vague ou micron est ce qu'on va dans la
bonne direction mais ce qu'il faudrait
pas que simplement reprendre la vie
normale mais ça que la grande bretagne
est leader et un peu en pole position
sur 7 sur cette sortie de crise c'est
fou en angleterre en espagne normand on
devrait suivre
l'israël aussi bien sur l'italie se pose
la question si d'arrêter ces tests parce
qu'en fait le problème c'est qu'on fait
des tests et les tests ont comme
conséquence de bloquer les gens chez eux
et d'empêcher la vie de reprendre et n'a
pas comme conséquence d'empêcher
l'épidémie de flamber sks un peu de 400
et 500 vous allez tous à 464 c'est la
conséquence de deux milliards de
dépenses et ses 2 milliards c'est rien
c'est sans compter tous les gens qui
vont pas travailler les gens qui vont
pas à l'école il faut sortir de cette
stratégie là et en plus en parallèle
qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya moins de
patients dans les services de relation
parce qu'on a le variant delta québec
désire donc il faut se calmer avec ce
variant micron et le pire c'est ce qu'on
voit en israël c'est que de publier des
chiffres tous les jours du nombre de cas
ça fait que même si vous faites un
retour à la vie normale les gens se
limite à eux mêmes parce que par exemple
en israël il ya plus aucune restriction
et les gens ne vont plus travailler
parce qu'à force de communiquer les
chiffres tous les jours les gens ce blog
nokia les autorités seraient en train de
se dire on va arrêter de publier les
chiffres parce que les gens puissent
reprendre une vie normale parce que ya
là l'état français pourrait dire on va
retourner à la vie normale mais les gens
se bloquerait si on continue donc en
fait il faut à la fois
permettre aux gens de problème est
normal il faut aussi arrêter avec ce
nombre de cas qu'on compte tous les
jours parce que ça n'a aucun impact en
tout cas sur les réanimations
aujourd'hui qui baisse c'est la nouvelle
que vous soyez pour qu'on reprenne une
vie normale ah oui novelli non mais de
toute façon c'est une question qui va se
poser là là le ministre c'est des bonnes
nouvelles que ce soit et une levée des
restrictions en angleterre en espagne et
bientôt en italie menus dit en israël en
israël c'est quand même des bonnes
nouvelles bah c'est une très bonne
nouvelle mais ça s'annonce qui voilà
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut se préparer
à reprendre la vie normale et le
problème c'est qu'on est en décalage en
france parce qu'on en sort de cette
polémique sur le passé iteere c'est à la
limite ce qui est un outil qui permet ce
qui incite les gens à se vacciner il
faut se vacciner c'est ça se pose pas
comme question mais en revanche ses
mesures de restriction nous coûterait
cher et on sait que l'hôpital est en
grande difficulté et je pense que c'est
2 milliards seraient mieux investis à
l'hôpital parce que à force de dépenser
autant pour bloquer le pays avec ces
tests c'est de l'argent qu'on n'aura pas
dispensés en suisse en même temps que je
lui en france pour savoir que c'est 2
milliards ne viendront pas un bulletin
ça c'est donc ces deux médias même si c
est ce qu il faut reprendre une vie
normale professeur camille notre vie
était normal il y a vingt ans avec la
réalité ville reine sinon tu revis a été
normal il y a deux ans avant que la
coved arrive et notre vie est normale
aujourd'hui parce que nous avons une vie
normale vis-à-vis de la réalité à
laquelle nous devons nous confronter et
vis-à-vis des missions que nous nous
donnons pour protéger les autres
personnes et nous aurons une vie normale
différentes dans quelques mois ou dans
quelques années en attendant mégalomane
et les missions que vous venez de
présenter sur l'évolution du racisme et
des comportements racistes allez
demander aux anciens salariés normale et
est normal il y avait un taux
aujourd'hui ce qu'on pouvait se
permettre il importe aujourd'hui c'est
une native on vit on vit normalement là
et donc ce qui veut dire
mon film n'est pas globalement si c'est
notre vie normale et la balance elle a
besoin voilà c'est le pousse et c'est de
ça dont on a besoin c'est la mesure ce
qu'est alors à quoi le leader puisque ça
n'empêche pas les rues de circuler on a
dit qu'on pouvait se situer et martin le
plasma le marais a indiqué l'élu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tous les tests je suis bien sûr d'accord
ça beaucoup moins de sens ok les tests
n'ont d'intérêt que si vraiment ils
servent à isoler les personnes parce que
le virus est extrêmement transmissibles
ou extrêmement dangereux et donc on veut
protéger les personnes ça sert à ça les
tests faire des tests juste pour savoir
je suis positif ou négatif ça n'avait
pas pour seul effet monsieur tous les
gens depuis nîmes ont rejoint tous les
jours on enfourne d'aller terminer
pour le nez
moi je le fais souvent les gens mais
maintenant je reçois des alertes sur moi
même en disant vous avez croisé
quelqu'un qui était positif oui c'était
pc je n'avais jamais reçu 16 e leur
souffrance même alors et alors est ce
qu'on doit voulait pas reprendre une vie
normale comme dit martin non moi alors
c'est moi c'est en angleterre en espagne
il lève les restrictions partout jeu par
exemple je prends énormément les
transports en commun j'aurais peur
soudain un truc qu'on n'ait plus de
masques je pense que je vais être un
métier alors eh bien ce sera un choix
personnel je pense que moi je le
garderais je ne veux pas non plus être
un ayatollah et imposer aux autres mais
je pense
je pense que je vais rester trop baptisé
pour l'instant est-ce que vous ça veut
dire qu'on s'est laissé le choix aux
gens vous pourriez y ressemble vous irez
dans le métro ou cyril
avait tout le temps c'est vrai problème
c'est que je porte un masque les gens me
reconnaissent voilà mr x vous avez pris
le métro que c'était pas on avait le
temps des recettes savoir tiens oui vous
avez été doigt ou mais qu'allez vous
dire aux cèdres mairie de montreuil j'ai
fait toute la ligne
vous savez qui est plus première classe
dans le métro c'est depuis un moment
tellement vous serez en première classe
du professeur casalino juste parce que
c'est vrai qu'à vous nous dites on vit
une vie normale maintenant pourquoi ils
ont levé toutes les restrictions partout
ailleurs et pourquoi pas en france alors
je pose la question retrouver
restrictions que ça ne veut rien dire
aujourd'hui que ce que nous avons comme
restrictions honnêtement c'est le merci
mais le mince mais le masque des
rhônalpins qui n'a pas une restriction
les employés le jeu chacun d'entre eux
mijo
50%
on est devant soyons lucides ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui représenta un
handicap colossal et sont ravis
non mais je vais au bout quand même vous
rappelle quand même
parce qu'il fallait protéger les autres
et je vous rappelle que aimer les autres
de ses les protégés énorme et moi je
pense que l'erreur fondamentale a été
numéro philosophique en france et les
hommes politiques et beaucoup de nos
responsables porte une responsabilité
au lieu de nous convaincre que faire des
choses intelligentes pour protéger les
autres c'était une preuve de cme et
d'amour pour les autres on nous a
convaincus que respecter ces mesures
étaient des contraintes et un nom
quand j'entends ça j'en profite pour
citer msiska
total
oui moi la raison non mais je suis
choqué par ce que j'entends ses fans
comme le covin nous a retourné sa
voiture nous en priver non mais on nous
a privé nos libertés pendant deux ans et
donc aujourd'hui on se satisfait de la
moindre petite liberté qu'on a pardon
c'est pas une vie normale de virey
cammas c'est pas une vie normale de 5
heures ce scanner bourreau des
conférences chez soi pour avoir un café
c'est pas une vie normale vous dites
c'est des petites restrictions il ya
plein de gens qui souffrent encore du
coville et qui vont souffrir des
conséquences plus tard du coc vide parce
que tous les prêts garantis par l'état
et ses tabous pas une vie normale le
retour à la vie normale c'est pas
enlever les jauges restrictions selon
lui c'est on va voir le coin spécial
donc on va être encore
oui c'est normal cela survient m&m
élément important si vous permettez
d'être un peu scientifique une seconde
c'était m'adresser d'aujourd'hui
et resterez les conséquences économiques
de la coved les conséquences et vous
avez raison psychologique les
conséquences sociétales de la cua vide
ne sont pas liés aux restrictions elles
sont liées à la peur que le fait d'être
confrontés à un ennemi invisible
difficile qui fait peur une pandémie
c'est pas un virus et nous une faune des
mystères l'été social et liens associés
leur maîtrise d'économie il réside